FOR TONIGHT'S #HASHTAG WARS.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
SUNDAY WAS THE HIGHEST OF HIGH
HOLIDAYS-- YES, I'M REFERRING TO
4/20.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
DENVER, WHERE CANNABIS IS NOW
LEGAL, THEY CELEBRATED WITH A
MASSIVE 4/20 RALLY THAT IF I MAY
BE SO BLUNT-- HA, HA-- GAVE
NEW MEANING TO THE PHRASE "MILE
HIGH CITY."
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
OUR HASHTAG TONIGHT IS #MUST
HAVEBEENHIGH, #MUSTHAVEBEENHIGH.
EXAMPLES MIGHT BE WATCHED
ANCHORMAN TEN TIMES FOR THE
POLITICAL SUBTEXT.
(LAUGHTER)
#MUSTHAVEBEENHIGH.
OR FOUND OUT I AM THE MAYOR OF
TORONTO, #MUSTHAVEBEENHIGH.
(LAUGHTER)
ALL RIGHT, I'M GOING TO PUT
60 SECONDS ON THE CLOCK AND GO.
KERRI KENNEY.
>> I THOUGHT MY SON'S SAXOPHONE
RECITAL WAS TOO SHORT.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: NICK.
>> IF YOU SPEND MORE MONEY ON
FROOT LOOPS THAN YOU DO ON RENT.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: POINTS.
MARLON.
>> I HAVE BEEN WATCHING A HONEY
BOOBOO MARATHON.
THAT BITCH IS DEEP.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: KERRI.
>> MY MOM'S 40-MINUTE STORY
ABOUT HER CAT WAS FASCINATING.
>> Chris: POINTS.
NICK.
>> IF YOU THOUGHT "AVATAR" WAS A
DOCUMENTARY.
(LAUGHTER)
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Chris: MARLON.
>> MY FINGERS TASTE LIKE
CHICKEN.
BUT MY THUMB TASTES LIKE
(BLEEP).
(AUDIENCE REACTS)
>> Chris: POINTS.
POINTS.
(LAUGHTER)
I WISH WE HAD MORE TIME TO GET
THE DETAILS OF THAT STORY.
POINTS.
NICK.
>> IF YOU HAVE HOT POCKETS FOR
THANKSGIVING DINNER.
(LAUGHTER)